نحييكم مشاهدينا الى بانوراما نناقش فيها
كالعاده ابرز الملفات اليوم في ملفاتنا
لهذا المساء بعد تردد وجدل دبابات قتاليه
غربيه في طريقها الى اوكرانيا كيف ستؤثر
الاسلحه الهجوميه الغربيه على المعارك وهل
اصبح اصطدام المباشر بين موسكو والغرب
وشيكا في ملفنا اسامي منورات امريكيه
اسرائيليه تحاكي استهداف مواقع نوويه
ايرانيه رساله تحضير فقط انت غير بالموقف
الامريكي وفي ملفنا الثالث الاحتجاجات
تعودوا للشارع العراقي بسبب انخفاض الزنار
فهل تهدد تظاهرات حكومه السوداني
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل اختبار هو الاول من
نوعه ستواجهه الدبابات الغربيه التي سيتم
ارسالها الى ساحه القتال في اوكرانيا
والطرف الثاني دبابات روسيه بعد اعلان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ارسل 31 دبابه
من طراز لاوكرانيا وبعد حوار مع الحلفاء
وبتوافق امريكي اعلنت الحكومه الالمانيه
الرسميه موافقتها على ارسال دبابات او
دبابات النمر الاكياس كما اعلنت اعتزامها
توفير الصيانه والذخيره لها والهدف هو
تشكيله
اوكرانيا بقوه 14 دبابه حيث اكد المستشار
الالمانيه
ستعمل على تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على
قياده وصيانه هذه الدبابات في حين اشارت
مجله
الالمانيه الى ان الدول الاوروبيه تسعى
لارسال 80 دبابه من الطرازيه ذاته
لاوكرانيا في اسرع وقت وفي احدث رد من
موسكو على صفقه الاسلحه المحتمله الى كياف
اكد رايس روسيه في مدينه بوتين بانه لن
يسمح باي تهديد للاراضي التاريخيه في
اشاره الى ان الغرض من العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا هو حمايه روسيا صحيفه الطيور
تايمز اكدتنا الجدل القائمه بشان تسليح
اوكرانيا بدبابات المتطوره ليس الخطوه
الصعبه وانما تكون الصعوبه في كيفيه نقله
هذه المركبات المدرعه الثقيله الى كياس
[موسيقى]
هناك شهاده
الدكتور الكسندر بجمولوف مدير المعهد
الوطني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم
ضيوفي اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من كيف معك يا
دكتور الكسندر في الواقع
الداخل الاوكراني كان ينتظر بفارغ الصبر
اذا صح التعبير الاعلان او الموافقه على
اا
دبابات لو بار فاتى من بعد الموافقه
الالمانيه اتى كذلك تصريح لرئيس الامريكي
يعلن فيه عن اا ارسال 31 كذلك دبابه
ابرامز واعتبر بان هذا هو اشار الى عيد
ميلاد الرئيس الاوكراني وقال بانه وكانها
هذه
للرئيس الاوكراني فسؤال المطروح هنا هذه
الهديه هل ستكون هديه حقيقيه قادره ان
تنهي هذه المعركه او ان هذه الهديه هديه
ملخصه وسيتم احراقها وهي خطوه فاشله كما
تحدث عن ناطق باسم الكرم
لا يعني صحيح ان هي يعني تصادف يعني مع
العائله الميلاد يعني ممكن تعبيره هذا
يعني
هذا يعني اما بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
للتوفير يعني بهذه المعدات الدبابات
بالذات فهو مترقب يعني خلال فتره طويله
جدا
القياده العسكريه كانت تطلب من زمان يعني
توفير هذه الدبابات فهي مهمه جدا لمواصله
الهجوم المعاكس على قوات الاحتلال يعني
ستلعب دورها ولا شك في ذلك ان في مواصله
همم
هل سيبدو هل دور فارق في المعركه او دوره
بسيط
ان شاء الله
حاسم يعني وليس حاسم حتما يعني ليس يعني
لا اتوقع انه يعني مجرد وصول الدبابات
سيحصل حرب يعني اما بالنسبه للمعارك
القادمه خلال الفتره القادمه هي الفتره
الربيع يعني خاصه ستكون الدوره حاسم جدا
لان هي دبابات احسن في العالم احسن جوده
في العالم من جميع المواصفات يعني انا همم
بالنسبه
همم
امريكيون وكذلك اوروبيون يقولون بان لي
بار حتى وان وصلت في همم تاريخ المحدد لها
وهو في شهر مارس ستكون هناك فتره للتدريب
وهم بداوا من اليوم في محاوله همم جدوله
طريقه تدريب وهنا سؤال سيد ساعود لك لا
يمكن علينا ان نحمل كل اعمالنا فقط على
الدبابه او تراث واحد هناك حزمه كبيره جدا
من السلاح يعني وهي في الطريقه
حتى نفهم لانك انت تتحدث عن ان هذه
الدبابات ستكون حاسمه همم دكتور بيجامه ما
رايك
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم ريما وللمشاهدين
فيكم الكريم
وربما في المستقبل قد نعطي الى مرحله اخرى
مثلا ارسال الطائرات المقاتله الى
اوكرانيه كما يطلب اجانب الاوكراني ساتلعب
دورا
لا استطيع ان يقول ان اقول الى قدر ماهو
ولكن ستلعب دورا كبيرا في حسبه هذه
المعركه خاصه بخلول شهر مارس يوليو لان
هناك
اختمال
سيتم تجميعه هناك نخوه 200 دببه دبابه
حديثه
لحلف الناطق مثل اليابارت وهي من امثل
والدبابات للمسرح على عمليات الاوكراني
فيما يتعلق ابرم سياسيه ثقيله لوزن ولكن
ايضا في الخطوه الكبيره من قبل الولايات
المتحده وهناك ترسانه هذه الدبابات في دول
اوروبا الشرقيه
وحامشي هنا انا المانيا اصدرت ترخيص
لغيرها من الدول لنقل هذه الدبابات
الاوكرانيا وستفعل ذلك مثلا طولاندا
وغيرها من الدول
وطبعا بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك الحديث
المدفعيه المدفعيه ايضا حديثا يعني يمكن
همم ان يصل عدد المطافي التي همم سيتم
تسليمها الى اوكرانيا الى 100 و 85 واخذه
منها 135 مدفع ذاتي الحركه يعني هو المهم
جدا لان حتى الان في الفتره الاخيره الروس
كانوا يستخدم
احتك تتكلم بكل براجماتيه وتعتبر حتى همم
وحضرتك روسي ولكن تعتبر بانه همم هذه
المجموعه الجديده من المساعدات العسكريه
من دبابات ومدافع همم وفق الضيفي بانها
ستكون حاسمه لهذه المعركه حسم كيف
وباختصار لو سمحت هل قادره على همم وقف
هذه الحرب ولصالح منه
للجانب الاوكرانيا الجانب الاوكراني راحن
على العمليه المضاده همم في همم في
اوكرانيا في جنوبها وتقرير كامل اراضيه
واما الجانب الروسي طبعا يعتبر كما قال
السيد الرئيس ان هذه اصبحت هي اولا على
راضيه التاريخيه الروسيه ثم بعد اجراء
الاستفتاء اصبحت جزءا من روسيا الاتحاديه
اذ ان هناك التضارب في المواقف وهنا جوهر
هذا الصراوي ولا يمكن حله في هذه المرحله
التي
همم على فن همم السياسه وكيفيه ايجاد
الحلول وهذا هو السؤال لانه صراع قائم
البعض يقول بانه مع الاعلان عن الموافقه
على تزويد كيف بهذه الدبابات نحن بطريقه
صريحه دكتور اليكساندر امام صراعا مباشر
غربي روسيا وكان حلف شمال الاطلسي اصبح
فردا فاعلا في هذا الصراع ما رايك
يعني عدم التدخل المباشر من قبل الدول
الغربيه ولا هناك تدخل يعني ولا رغبه ولا
من حارس المبدا ليست هناك ضروره يعني لا
يتدخل القوات الاوكرانيه قويه يعني همم من
حيث العدد وكذلك من حيث الجوده الاصلع
خالد موجوده وكذلك معاركيه فنحن لسنا
بحاجه الى تدخل المبارك
انه اولا روسيا لا تعتبر وان التدخل الغرب
هو التدخل المباشر ذلك روسيا تقول انه هو
التدخل غير المباشر ولكن
موسكو تعتبروا الغرب كطرفا في هذا النظام
طرف غير مباشر ولكن كانت هناك تصريحات
روسيه رسميه مفادها بان لو وافقت المانيا
والغرب على تزويد كيف بهذه الدبابات
فسنعتبر ذلك تدخلا مباشرا في هذا الصراع
نام ولكن يجب ان تكون هناك بعض الشروط
اولا كيف سيتم هذا التدخل هناك التصريحات
الناريه من قبل بعض والمحللين الروس
واحيانا خطي بعض
المسؤولين دائما يتحدثون من الخطوط الحمر
ولكن يجب فعل ذلك ويجب الانتقال مثلا هناك
الطرف الذي يطلب الانتقال الى الافعال
وليس الاقوال ولكن شخصيا انا اعتقد انه
حتى الان الامور لم تصل الى النقطه التي
نستطيع ان نتحدث فيها ان اصطدام المباشر
بين روسيا والغرب في اراضي اوكرانيا
وشو بيصيران مباشره عسكريه بين روسيا وحلف
الناطق نحن الان في مرحله الدبابات
والمدفعيه اذا صحت همم فقط
بابات ومدفعيه نتحدث كذلك عن همم
ممرينين عن مدربين همم الدول العربيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المانيا تتحدث
عن ان مسؤولين امريكيين والمنهم من
سيقومون بتدريب القوات هذا لا تعتبرونه
همم يعني تدخل مباشر
لا همم هو تداخل غير مباشر هو التداخل غير
مباشر وليس التدخل مباشر لان على مدى عشره
اشهر
مدربين ونشهد والخبراء العسكريين وهناك
الدعم المباشر من قبل اجهزه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه للجانب الاوكراني وموسكو تتحدث
عن خطوط حمراء ولكن يبدو ان الكريم يعتبر
ان هو الوقت لم يحن همم
[موسيقى]
للشني هجوم مباشر ضد
هذا
الحديثه مثل هذه الامكانيه
او تفسيرات واقعيه في تعليق كلنا منهما
ولكن همم هناك مخاوف دكتور الكسندر هنا
كما خوف بخصوص التصعيد لان البعض وصفا
تزويد كيف بهذه الدبابات والمدفعيات بانه
قرار تاريخ خاصه قرار المانيا هناك مخاوف
من اندلاع ما يسمى بالحرب العالميه
الثالثه بشكل من الاشكال هل هذا وارد او
مبالغ فيه باختصار
العالميه الثالثه او التدخل الغربي يعني
هي عباره عن حرب نفسيه اللي هي كذلك جزء
من الحرب التي شنته الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اما بالنسبه لتبيعه الحرب يعني كما هي فهي
حرب دفاعيه كل الحرب كل العمليات
الاوكرانيه هي همم عباره هجوم معاكس يعني
وليس هجوم على العراق
مقدسه او غير مقدسه الروسيه احنا همم نسمه
لدينا رغبه ولم تكن ان تدخل في شؤون
الروسيه وحتى همم لا نريد ولا شبر من
الروضه الروسيه احنا فقط ندافع عن انفسنا
فما تقوم بها همم الاطراف الغربيه هي مجرد
مسانده وليست تدخل هي مساعدات مساعدات همم
شرعيه همم مطبقه يعني 100% يعني مبنيه همم
[موسيقى]
المتحده لانه همم
على حق اي بلد مستقل همم دفاع عن سيادتها
واعراضها عن سلامه اراضيها وكذلك عن همم
عن همم
كذلك حق الدول
المتخالفه ومثمده
يبقى في متابعه دكتور
اليكساندر بجمولوف مدير المعهد الوطني
الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من كيف
والدكتور رولاندو بيجامه في المحلل اساسي
شكرا لكم